oh you know I've been feeling a little
bit of anxiety you know like you know
and with the jetlag and everything it
always makes anxiety is right this is
not a dream I'm a tree it's not a gnat
reading and so you know it always you
know when I'm feeling tired and and
aiways sleep-deprived a little bit it
always you know fuels my anxiety a
little bit and I think in my head I
think how can i what can I do to combat
this how can i what can I do to feel
more relaxed you know I'm sure we all
feel like that yeah wait what
just for a second would be so funny to
just do an ad read 30 seconds okay how
was your weekend it's great man
how was yours it was all right pretty
hungover but you know how I got over it
full send yeah hangover cure bro I
watched that clip back which one of us
okay to be that Kyle on musk in elk yeah
yeah I was crying so [ __ ] funny
they're [ __ ] video today dude I
haven't washed it yet but isn't it dude
like [ __ ] like I don't know it's like
some kid in there crew now yeah and he
like lost his virginity like a porn star
or something yeah yeah just on camera
yeah it's like dude I don't know I don't
know if that's a great decision
yeah don't do it but don't [ __ ] on
film you don't film it you know you six
seven years from now you're my God why
did I did yeah any what I mean good on
private sex yeah that's always good yeah
anyways anxiety yeah well luckily my boy
JP jump is hot tweet yesterday yeah
banger I'll read this remember anxiety
is created by you sometimes you gotta
let life play out and remind yourself to
be happy and that the answers will come
chill your mind out go for a walk talk
to a friend and that's a tweet and so I
read that and it actually made me feel
better although I feel like he didn't go
hard enough with this tweet you know I
read this and I want to know is this for
us Jake or is it for you it's only you
talking to yourself like this is like
that like not it up like
like a high ladder of people on a people
high up on the corporate ladder like do
[ __ ] like this and like paste it to
their [ __ ] computer monitor mm-hmm
Oh like it's a yeah like her daily
remind yeah it's like a it's like a
saying yeah yeah what's n't the creator
of my own exit it's like an anime
creator of my own anxiety yeah yeah ever
Mason I like I don't know no I feel like
I feel like you know I feel like he's
got a great point and I feel like he
should have went even further with this
he should he should blame like really
lay the blame on the person we are
feeling anxious you know it's your girl
he's your [ __ ] fault yeah stupid
brain it's just your puny little brain
that makes you have anxiety all you got
to do is
listen here [ __ ] chill out you
jackass yeah the whole reason you're
[ __ ] anxious is cuz you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I don't know if you knew that and
if you weren't so [ __ ] dumb all the
time maybe you wouldn't be so anxious
cuz you're dumb as nails talk to a
friend you little you ever gone outside
you [ __ ] loser
yeah huh you I bet you forgot how to go
outside that's how [ __ ] dumb you are
you dumbass go out and look at some
trees chill your mind out go for a
[ __ ] hike you dunce
we gotta make like a positivity book
that's just that yeah it's it's $1.00
and it's all it's a hundred and it's a
it's ten thousand sayings where it's
just cussing it you mean it's called
relax dumbass yeah first page before
[ __ ] walk idiot it's like that's so
funny actually that's a [ __ ] kind of
a genius idea should just do that yeah
like a self-help book but it's all super
[ __ ] Mia it's condescending yeah take
it from me a rich person you're stupid
yeah it's too good not even even the
thing to help you just like oh I'm dumb
okay I don't I just want to know you can
do anything if you set your [ __ ]
stupid-ass little mind to it maybe if
you collect all your IQ points you can
finally do something about your rings
yeah yeah oh you can fix the fact that
you're such a [ __ ] loser
[Laughter]
funny it's like lifting you up but
putting you down at the same time yeah
and they're just by the end of it it's
like a horrible [ __ ] like shaming your
body yeah yeah the first pages so you've
bought this book to better yourself
because clearly you're in a [ __ ] rut
yeah and you're at the lowest point in
your stupid-ass life and so you finally
[ __ ] took a step in the right
direction finally after all these
[ __ ] years you'll loser
so nice work next page drink your [ __ ]
I'll drink your con [ __ ] your mom
should have had an abortion but she
didn't so what are the next steps looks
like you're down on your luck get bent
anyway dude I'd really I don't you know
we don't have to this isn't this isn't
like a [ __ ] we're not like defusing a
bomb here it's not anything complicated
I just want to know what's going through
his head that he's like doing all this
weird like grant cardone [ __ ] like
yeah I know but that didn't he make
enough money from his last his boxing
matches so I was thinking I don't get
this I'd really don't get this the kid
is that he's really trying to make the
subscription subscription thing pop off
because like that's look if you can make
that work oh like some Tony Robbins
[ __ ] no no I'm talking about like
the monthly didn't you see like the but
I know but that's like some Tony Robbins
[ __ ] yeah yeah twenty bucks a month yeah
um but if you lock in [ __ ] you know
whatever mm kids thanks box of monkey
what is that it's $200,000 dark [ __ ]
though man that's really dark [ __ ] foots
42 you got it [ __ ] twenty times
twenty nine two thousand kids paying
twenty bucks a month for that stupid
course herb that's 40 grand a month yeah
but I mean that's where I look at I
don't like don't you have enough bro
don't you have enough yeah but he's got
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you think he
needs it I mean I don't know what do you
think that the lease payment has at
least a mortgage payment on that giant
ass house yeah the thing is [ __ ] huge
like nine cars hmm yeah yeah that's I
mean that's a I don't know that's
another wheel who even cares talk about
any more I gave a [ __ ] I just thought
this was really funny yeah like why even
yeah just just you know heads IDs of
choice yeah yeah I love how
condescending is in that video to about
like you can't like I wasn't the best in
school but look at me I'm [ __ ] rich
it's like he has no idea why he's right
yeah yeah he knows what to do with the
money and he knows I don't like
manipulate his crowd but he doesn't he's
not a self-aware to know like how he
actually got there I know and it's like
no dude most people have like [ __ ]
like shame and self-awareness and they
could never have the gall yeah to do the
things that you do yeah that's why
you're where you're at you're a
spectacle I agree with that
what like you know he it's it's I don't
know I feel like people that aren't
self-aware it's like almost easier for
them to like get rich on stupid [ __ ] it
is they just can't no they don't grasp
the fact that oh they don't there's no
shame there's no embarrassment there's
like [ __ ] I'm just gonna know they
don't care that too like 95% of people
it looks like a gigantic [ __ ]
but that 5% that's like [ __ ]
religious about what they do and like
doubles down on them as a fan it's like
that they live for that yeah which is a
that's a weird place to be man I don't
know he had this did you see the tweet
about his program that he started or
whatever nah if you're confused at
whether he put this on a story it's all
like [ __ ] written out over there oh
yeah yeah yeah if you're confused at
what the event is tomorrow basically I'm
sick of our education system and how it
is hit zero real life skills yeah you're
their own future and there is spelt
wrong I'm creating a movement for
everyone who wants to take life into
their own hands and learn real life
skills from actual professionals dude
writing is a [ __ ] real life skill
yeah you just spelt they're wrong and
[ __ ] in the first sentence about your
educational program and how much the
school system has failed you it sounds
like a basic a skill like a school you I
don't know yeah sure there should be
classes about doing taxes I agree with
that yeah or like yeah there should be
more like entrepreneurial classes maybe
in high school or whatever this system
has been around for ever for a [ __ ]
reason yeah here's another thing man
education is not perfect but I'm gonna
say this like um I mean that minimum
algebra teaches you stuff like solving
for unknowns like that's a life skill
yeah like if you have this and you have
that how the [ __ ] do you get to this
it's like that like concept is it
carries through a lot of things and let
me tell you what the [ __ ] you said
they're like what well
he like he's like why you learning
pythagorean's theorem when [ __ ] you
know you know who uses math dude the
people who [ __ ] wrote the platform
that you [ __ ] benefit from and that
you profit from imma say this again the
people who [ __ ] design and build the
hardware that supports the [ __ ]
platform and the [ __ ] thing called
the Internet yeah you know who else
[ __ ] benefits from writing in the
education system all the lawyers who
doctor up your [ __ ] contracts all
your dumb [ __ ] products yeah it's
like that's the [ __ ] that actually gets
under my skin yeah it's like all these
people go to skip go to school and they
learn real skills and he benefits from
that and he's got the [ __ ] nerve to
get on there and be like - schools were
[ __ ] idiot yeah it's like no dude
you're an idiot who sucked at school
yeah that's it yeah and then [ __ ]
sadly 2,000 other idiots like him are
gonna be like you do you really need as
a course yeah
[ __ ] out here don't you see the irony
and telling people school sucks and then
charging them to [ __ ] learn oh that
was the biggest gripe with the whole
thing was that people are like what do
you did what are you doing what are you
talking about you're just that's cool
just go to [ __ ] all of the plenty of
like Skillshare or any of these [ __ ]
web sites where you can just learn for
free yeah why you gonna pay Jake Paul 20
bucks
don't you gotta be a [ __ ] youtuber
yeah oh yeah it's it's also kind of like
weird that like now he's sick of it
he's been out of school for ever you
know but now he's like you know what I'm
sick of this [ __ ] what like what made
you sick of it yeah this move it someone
like came to a meet-and-greet and asked
him to like do their homework and he got
pissed off circumference of it he was
like [ __ ] anyways [ __ ] this man I'm
inspired you know what revolutionize
this [ __ ] it's so offended yes to
destroy school because it beat his ass
school beat his ass circumference that
you dude I'm not gonna [ __ ] find the
circumference of this [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] dummy man I'm [ __ ] hated
everyone clowning my tweet but it's now
spreading a more awareness about anxiety
which I didn't even know was the thing
until I was 18 but had it my father's
mother [ __ ] [ __ ] you Jake you're gonna
take credit for telling people about
anxiety
I need a do till he was 18 but then what
[ __ ] cured it just by one going on a
walk right now let's go to Wikipedia
let's see one fly had I had anxiety
undiagnosed until I was 18 and then I
[ __ ] figured it out yeah and I went
in outside and I had a hour-long
conversation with a tree and it fix it
okay whoo-hoo I went and I played
hopscotch with a friend and it was done
Pierre Janet in 1859 developed the idea
that anxious manifestations could be
triggered by subconscious fix ideas so
Jake I must say you are comfortably a
thousand years late you are one thousand
you know matter of fact I went to school
so I can do the math on this
what is this forty one thousand plus
twenty your 1061 years late - you're 18
stupid years yeah
so that's [ __ ] what fit thousand
fifty three congratulations brother at
birth and whatever I don't care
do what if tomorrow all the headlines
are like Jake Paul cures anxiety like
Medical Journal uh yeah we're just like
wrong as five famous youtube sensation
has found the cure for anxiety it's
simply take a walk call a friend yeah
whatever
kid can [ __ ] kick can buy our [ __ ]
book and get his life and life together
yeah dude
you